good morning illuminations my name is
Lillian Bob and right when word is
extraordinary I believe that every human
being is capable doing extraordinary
things so to help you on your journey
today's message is follow your heart
overseas leading the rock jungle I found
that with depression one of the most
important things you could realize is
that you're not alone you're not the
first to go through it you're not gonna
be the last to go through it and
oftentimes it happens you just you feel
like you're alone and you feel like it's
only you and you're in your bubble and
and I wish I had someone at that time
who could just pull me aside may gonna
be okay okay I wish I knew that just got
to remember hold on to that fundamental
quality of faith have faith
and on the other side of your pain is
something good after about a month and a
half of staying in that little apartment
and cleaning I got a phone call from the
head coach of the team who cut me head
coach of the cowberry Stampeders he
called me and he said hey I know we cut
you but I'd like you to come back I said
okay I appreciate that coach thank you
very much I'll think about it he said
okay great I hung up the phone and my
dad said gonna do it right said no I
don't think so I think I'm done with
that he goes what I said my gut tells me
I'm done he said what he gonna do I took
a deep breath I said I'd like to get
into the business he said what business
I said the wrestling business he says
you are throwing it all away
it is a worst mistake you'll ever make
he said you're ruining your career so
maybe I'll be no good but I feel like in
my heart I have to do this and I either
need you to train me or need you to not
train me my dad rose to the occasion so
much right and it wound up being one of
the greatest chapters in my life
a lot of people don't follow their heart
instead for they do with a look it's a
list of things that could go wrong and
all the people would be disappointed
them if it does go wrong and he ends up
talking themself completely out of this
opportunity that we have in front of us
I precisely remember the moment that
Evans offered me to work and mentor
under him full-time and he was just
saying a lot of details and all I could
focus on with my heart my heart would
say yes I'm going to pick on this honor
aridity but I still have to keep my
composure because
wanted him to go through the details
with me and currently sells the first
time in years I actually followed plan
delicious I always hide myself as
someone who is very logical every
opportunity that came my way I would
make a list of all the things that's
involved I would make a list of all the
people that's going to be involved and
all the finances are involved and what I
are doing is doing nothing I assist and
do nothing and nothing happy with my
life and soon all of that just a massive
huge amount of regret every single day
and I'm going to regret not making on
this opportunity they get which is
overseeing everything through and in
started to think about when I'll resent
that
what would I do with all these regrets I
didn't want to regret not taking on
opportunities anymore so before I even
got a chance to think about he offered
he gave me my heart to say yes and I was
going to take it on and I knew it was
going to work out cause it's all right
deep inside me even though a lot of
people started questioning and while you
don't really feel it this is time you
even know what the plan is you don't
know if it's going to pan out and I just
kind of start back and love to myself no
it's going to work out because I have
faith that we're doing the right thing
and I'm so glad that I actually listen
to my heart and not my brain
overthinking things constantly because
every morning dinners because I am so
fulfilled with my life and I know every
day and walk in and I work I know I'm
living only dream and I'm not going to
regret and use it so I challenge you
this time you find yourself at a
crossroads of an opportunity don't
overthink anything just do and follow
your hands so the question of the day is
when was the last time you followed your
heart I would love to read your comments
so special shoutouts was to leave their
Kyoto
Felipe's thank you so much we have a
copy of Emmons both your one word and I
hope you enjoyed it as much as I did so
Rica guys so much for watching I believe
in you and a home you can see to believe
in yourself and whatever your one word
is and we'll see you tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso
Paul when you first signed up for the
first one which is back in like 99 2000
and did you think you'd be sitting here
in 2013 talking about number six no by
the chance
no screenplay nothing when I signed on I
was just an idea I was funny because uh
I wanted to do it you know working with
my friends because I'd already worked
with these people before and I like you
can't do it my representatives at home
you can't do it escape there's nothing
and then he didn't listen to their
advice
alright I got lucky but I just you know
following your heart kind of thing and
it wasn't even about down the road it
was about living in the moment
this young dedicated artist can't help
but reflect on those who once doubted
him they never said I wasn't talented
enough if they come like the industry
shade you'll need to be doing it I
respect their team but at the end of the
day I have to follow my heart is what I
want to do compassion can shaken and I
be hurt now if I this equation for
always be on my what is it about
investment and entrepreneurship that
sort of has bitten you I never look at
it as investments believing that I just
look at it as partnerships help changing
the world and just being part of
something that's inspiring my business
people uptown whenever they talk about
money you get asking my god I don't want
to hear but if they bring an idea to me
that I think is going to go to the next
level most of the time if I follow my
heart and everything else will fall in
place I've never ever done a deal a we
got the seed company we throw some
pinstripes in the soup you give me a
hundred thousand we sell 20 of them we
make I've never did a deal where it was
always based on money
I've always did my business deals based
on felt it was going to go in the future
our Father was going to help and inspire
somebody